speaking of trade possibilities sharing
let's pivot now to the new orleans
saints and michael thomas and
i strongly believe at this point that he
will not be traded
i do know this i know that there was an
effort
from thomas's camp to try to get a team
to make the saints an
offer that they couldn't slash wouldn't
refuse
that doesn't mean thomas wants out
per se it doesn't mean the saints want
to move him
it just means that maybe someone wanted
that option to at least
be on the table and the problem is no
one was willing to even put together the
kind of offer that it would have taken
because it's going to take a lot to
prime away from the saints saints are
going to take a 20 million
dead cap charge next year if they would
trade him now and they've gotta accept
the fact that they'd have to go forward
for the rest of the season without him
the reality is
they've played most of this season
without him and they're four and two but
if he comes back if he's healthy if
everything is pointed in the right
direction if he's learned his lesson if
he complies
with what the team wants there was that
article from jeff duncan of the athletic
that again i don't think
he dug up the information in a dumpster
somewhere i think it was
handed to him by the saints to get the
message out to get the word out
to get michael thomas in a position
where he does what the team wants
but as of right now i'd be stunned if he
gets traded
but i do know that there was at least
from thomas's perspective
an effort to try to get someone to go to
the saints with something
and that didn't pan out
the saints have sent him an awful lot of
messages this year mike
and and if he doesn't get those into his
head by now he's probably not going to
if i'm drew brees i go try to repair
this relationship
however i have to repair this
relationship i just think the saints are
a better team
with him than with that and we just
talked about maybe this doesn't change
the browns i think
absolutely michael thomas changes the
look of the saints what they do he
commands that
presence on the field that defensive
coordinators and defenses have to worry
about
he in my mind he's one of the top five
if not top two or three receivers in the
nfl
and i just think when you look across
the line at him you know he's going to
go make his catches he had 149 last
season which
demolished the nfl record he's that good
and so if i'm the saints i'm not looking
to trade him i'm looking to repair that
relationship to get him back on the
field because i know i need him to go
beat the buccaneers
and to go do what we want to do in the
playoffs which is try to win another
super bowl before drew brees gets
finished
and he's almost finished as we well know
yeah and i i i think that the problem is
there's a level of intensity and
competitiveness and just
desire for michael thomas that that
can't always be harnessed
the right way and it does manifest
itself in ways
it practiced punching a teammate some of
the other things that came out just
boorish behavior
and and when you got a guy who was that
focused and that
driven and that motivated sometimes it
is hard to flip the switch on and off
and i think that may be part of the
issue and i think in a year when
he came into the season sharing saying
he wanted to do even better than 149
and he exits week one and he's gone
ever since then and he'll be back week
eight at the earliest
that's going to contribute to more
frustration and it's going to make you
feel like you're not in control of your
game of your life of anything
and it may it may spill over you know we
have bad days sometimes when we take it
out on the people around us that happens
the challenge is finding a way to to
reel that in and i think that's what the
saints are trying to get him to do but
he will be with the saints for the rest
of the year barring something
incredibly unexpected at this point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports